Thomas has 400 candy bars in his shop
and each costs 50 cents let P of B
denote the price P measured in dollars
of a purchase of B candy bars alright I
input B the number of candy bars I want
to buy and P of B will tell me well
what's the purchase price it's really
she's going to take the number of candy
bars and multiply by 50 cents but we
don't have to worry about that just yet
which number type is more appropriate
for the domain of the function so let's
just remind ourselves what is a domain
of a function a domain is a set of all
inputs over which the function is
defined so it's the set of all B's it's
the set of all inputs over which P of B
will produce a defined response so let's
think about it is it integers or real
numbers so I could buy B could be zero
candy bars one candy bars two candy bars
all the way up to 400 candy bars could I
could I have a fractional K could I
could be B 0.37 to of a candy bar well
if this is a a normal candy shop it's in
each candy bar is going to be in its own
packet it's going to be in a discrete
chunk you're not going to be able to buy
0.37 to of a candy bar you're either
going to buy a one more or not more so
you buy 0 1 2 3 all the way up to 400 so
I would say integers that the domain of
this function is going to be is going to
be a subset of integers it's not you're
not you can't have a real all real
number inputs integers are obviously a
subset of real numbers but you can't say
hey I'm going to buy PI candy bars I or
I'm going to buy the square root of 2
candy bars you're going to buy integer
number of candy bars
now they say define the interval of the
domain so the fewest candy bars I could
buy are zero candy bars and I have to
decide what do I put a bracket I put a
parenthesis so I can actually buy zero
candy bar so I'm going to put a bracket
if I put a parenthesis that means I
could have values above zero but not
including zero but I want to include
zero so I'm going to put the bracket
there so the least I could buy is zero
and then the most I could buy the store
has 400 candy bars so that's the most I
can buy the most I could buy of 400
candy bars and I can buy 400 so I would
put
brackets there as well so the interval
of the domain I would want to select
integers so B is a member of integers
such that B is also a member of this
interval it can be as low as zero
including zero and as high as four
hundred including four hundred got it
right